[Music]
this morning on the dish
a master of the wine glass sommelier
vanessa price opens her book by writing
sincere is a town in the loire valley of
france that
produces benchmark sabian blanc with
crazy acidity
pure minerality and cheek puckering
citrus
it goes perfectly with cheetos sincere
and cheetos go together like milk and
cookies
well bryce has worked in all aspects of
the wine industry and
writes a column in new york magazine
where she helps uncork
the secrets of wine pairings she's added
to that collection
in big macs and burgundy wine pairings
for the real world
one of the things that makes the big mac
so iconic is its special sauce right
to vanessa price it isn't a happy meal
without a glass of wine
and red burgundy it's got the same zesty
sort of savory profile as the sauce and
the big mac
ah and you want a little bit of a tannic
profile which is what protein needs
and you're going to get that from the
red wine and a pinot noir
has just the amount a right amount of
restraint to sort of make it all work
together and balance
exactly price's book big macs and
burgundy isn't just the ultimate wine
list
it's a guide for what to pair with
practically any food
or snack you can think of and the
science behind it
there are chapters for food from trader
joe's
wines for breakfast and even roadside
attractions like
cheez-its twinkies and cheetos sauvignon
blanc inherently has
high acidity it's a very crisp very
fresh wine the sort of
savory salty cheesiness of the cheeto
goes well with that minerality so the
flavors get enhanced
i like that don't feel like washing down
a pb and j with a glass of milk
how about a glass of a sparkling red
have you ever had a lambrusco
no i haven't and it looks very
interesting like you have a real tough
time opening that puppy up
yep there you go this is another one of
my favorites because it's such an
unexpected wine so many people haven't
tried lambrusco before
so you got bitterness from pb j you got
sweetness from jelly you got this
chewy sort of chunky element from it all
together with the bread
because this is a red wine it's got
tannins oh my god
the sweetness goes with the pb oh my god
and then the bubbles
wash it all clean oh my god
price's book is also a road map of her
sideways journey to becoming a sommelier
your original career goals were nothing
like what you're doing now no no no i
she writes about a chance encounter with
matt damon at a nightclub in miami
that put her on a new course he started
telling the story about how
he dropped out of harvard to write
goodwill hunting and people told me it
was crazy
and so i decided i was going to get on a
plane and i was going to go back to
kentucky and i was going to figure out
how to be an actress
price would move between new york and
louisville for
acting school then college before
pursuing
acting full-time and it was only because
i ended up having a college job doing a
little bit of waitressing that i finally
found myself close
enough to wine as a culture that i went
oh this is interesting maybe i could do
this and you know
i didn't actually know what that meant i
just kind of thought i'll figure it out
once she had
it was time to tell her father an
admiral
in the u.s navy and he had sort of said
so you're moving back to new york and i
said yeah and he said
then you're going to be an actress and i
said no i'm going to be a sommelier
and he turned around he looked at me he
was like osama what
over the past 15 years price has worked
in numerous capacities in the wine
industry
there's a whole chapter on what to pair
to cobb salad spinach salad kale salad
including as a wine rep selling to
restaurants
like the venerated carbone in new york
in her book she pairs their spicy
rigatoni pasta
with a chianti i hear this is the place
to eat new york
right now impossible to get a
reservation and to go with this
pairing hold up sorry this is your first
time having it
that melts in your mouth i actually
opened carbon as an account when i was a
sales rep
and this was actually this wine the
corchabella chianti was the chianzi by
the glass
when carbon open i don't like chianti oh
this is it's the pairing it's the
pairing and this is another level
chianti
cheers cheers but not everyone was such
an easy
sell her toughest customers have been
her conservative family members
my parents didn't drink my grandparents
didn't drink my grandmother she used to
call me
crying because she thought i just got
drunk for a living until one day when
her 81 year old grandfather hoodie
did something completely unexpected
he said you know it's very clear that
you've made your life in this
and you seem to have a lot of passion
for it i think that
it would be wrong of me to not try to
understand it
and so i would like for christmas if you
would bring home
a bottle for us to try together
i i am not joking i thought my dad was
going to fall out of his chair
my cousins were going this is amazing do
they like it i remember it was like you
know everybody was like
you know just like watching to see what
was going to happen and i remember my
grandmother sort of tasted it and she
was like
it's fine and then you know my
grandfather like we were all sort of
chatting and teasing her and then we
looked over and he'd already finished
his class
vanessa price seems to have that effect
on everyone
this is an example of a congruent
pairing so it sort of envelops the mac
and cheese
yes yeah i couldn't even go dry for a
month
in her presence cheers thank you thank
you for
going on this ride with me i appreciate
it i appreciate it
in dry january a trooper you're a
trooper to do this anything for
the craft you know so i blew it
so i decided to bring some for you guys
you've got to try this
my favorite pairing obviously the pb j
this was my number two the one i didn't
like so much was the fried chicken and
champagne which is the sommelier's
favorite to begin with what do you think
you definitely like the lambrusco oh god
oh god
oh god enough jeff enough i'm not joking
on that i'm just joking what do you
think
so this is this is cheetos and sunsets
this is cheap i mean here's the thing
it's cheetos and sansare that's good on
its own
don't you taste the the the
the essence of the cheeto coming out in
the sanceiro don't you
i don't but they both taste delicious
and i don't mean that in a bad way
you're a wine wrap now i'm trying well
you know i'm trying
so jealous of you getting to do this i
know we were like
i was mad when i heard you got it yeah
so thank you greg merman
the book looks cool it was super cool
and i just want to say one thing she
she is going to open a restaurant in
montauk which is in the hamptons called
mavericks montauk in the spring of 2022
she's going to be serving these pairings
there so congrats to her
big macs and burgundy